Hi! My name is Kunal and I'm delighted that
you are considering this course. Now, before we dive in,
I want to introduce myself and also share with
you two reasons why I'm really excited to teach this
course. First, I love teaching. Before joining Udacity, I
was a sixth-grade science teacher in India. I remember really
enjoying presenting new ideas to my students. That would
make them question what they already knew. That experience lead
me to pursue a Master's Degree from the School of
Education at Stanford University. The second reason, is that I love
to create things with programming. Now, in this course, we are
going to use the Python programming language to create a bunch
of projects. And my hope is that you would want to
share these projects with your friends. Here are some of them.
The first one, is project take a break. Do you know
a friend who works too many hours? Hint, that person could
be you. We will write a program that schedules
breaks throughout the day, reminding that individual to listen to
music, get up and dance to their favorite song,
or just walk away from the computer every once in
awhile. Another one is called project profanity editor. Imagine
you get an email from your boss, requesting your help
with something. You reply, I can take a shot
at it but accidentally you end up including an awkward
word. Oops. We will write a short Python program that detects curse
words and saves you from embarrassing moments in the future. The final project
is project movie databases. In this project we will learn how to make an awesome
webpage, that lists your favorite movies, and shows their trailers. [SOUND]
[MUSIC]